sur le canton de
Hérouville et de Colombelles une
victoire une victoire que je n'attendais
pas aussi aussi importante près de 59%
des le deuxième tour cela montre encore
une fois cette politique de proximité
que j'ai pu initier c'est quatre
dernières semaines il fallait rendre
compte bien sûr sur un bilan en tant que
mère mais aussi en tant que conseiller
départemental et le travail a été fait
particulièrement en direction des
colombes belloises et de Colombes et
lois parce qu'on a un véritablement
senti une détresse une détresse sur
laquelle malheureusement le département
ou le conseiller général précédent n'a
pas du pu prendre la mesure et que ce
soit sur l'emploi sur le cadre de vie
sur la formation et sur l'habitat par
exemple on sent un ras-le-bol un
désintérêt total de des élections en
général et ça s'est traduit au travers
les abstention ce soir et la semaine
dernière donc à nous de d'essayer de
rendre l'engagement politique dans le
bon sens du terme avec des valeurs
au-delà des clivages politiques les
habitants en or ras-le-bol en ont marre
de ces clivages que je crois entre
l'umpps les habitants veulent à notre
discours une autre approche une entente
les écouter et malheureusement on le
voit dans les débats nationaux c'est pas
comme ça qu'on va redorer le blason du
politique en soi et c'est à nous
localement et je pense où je suis
persuadé par expérience maintenant que
tout passera sur le local et justement
au niveau local au niveau départemental
vous allez rejoindre un conseil
départemental qui garde ça sa majorité à
droite c'était important bah oui parce
que je l'ai dit je l'ai rappelé pendant
cette campagne à l'ensemble des
habitants d'Hérouville de Colombelles
tout ce qui a pu apporter le département
au temps de Anne d'Ornano et aujourd'hui
avec Jean-Louis Dupont qui a porté des
réponses sur la rénovation urbaine sur
l'insertion sociale et professionnelle
sur l'emploi le développement économique
on dit souvent que la ville d'Hérouville
a changé et c'est une fierté pour moi
bien sûr depuis que je suis maire mais
sans le département vous m'entendez bien
sans le département nous n'en serions
pas là parce que le déplacement a bien
compris la situation économique et
sociale d'euroville et bien le
conseiller général que je suis que j'ai
été donc depuis maintenant 2008 à
essayer d'apporter des réponses et ses
réponses assez concrétiser sur des
actions justement pour lutter contre
contre le chômage dans les quartiers les
plus défavorisés sur la rénovation
urbaine comme je le disais sur le
transport tout ça biboutabout il y a des
piliers comme je dis souvent qui sont
fondamentaux et ce à quoi je me suis
toujours battu et je compte bien sûr
continuer cette cette belle aventure
mais mais sans aucune posture
individuelle moi ce que je veux c'est de
faire partager partager et que ne
surtout pas baisser les bras et qu'il y
a des alternatives à condition que tout
le monde allait se rassemblent et se
rassemblent au-delà des clivages
politiques avec un seul objectif trouver
des situations par rapport à ce que
peuvent subir une bonne partie de la
population en France et particulièrement
sur mon canton donc je vais m'y atteler
pendant ces prochaines semaines
prochains mois parce que encore une fois
c'est les électeurs m'ont fait confiance
à moi de leur rendre aussi l'appareil et
d'apporter des réponses c'est ce à quoi
je vais m'atteler dès demain matin
d'ailleurs